The Joe Rogan Experience but I remember
when I think in my mind is undeniably
the goat as again a just above casual
fan Jon Jones Jon Jones is the goat now
it's undeniable there was all this
debate until he submitted Cyril gone and
became the heavyweight champion no one
can [__] with that smashed him bro and
Cyril looked kind of unbeatable up until
the Francis fight well the Francis fight
exposed one aspect of his game that
you're never going to beat John in and
that's the wrestling yeah and then
everybody said well he didn't know that
France was going to wrestle him given
Francis is not the caliber wrestler or
even in the realm of Jon Jones Jon Jones
been wrestling since he was 12 years old
he took down Daniel Cormier who's an
Olympic level wrestler there is not a
guy in the world that can say that
you could start wrestling at 29 years
old I mean I mean you'd have to be the
freakiest of freak athletes to be able
to compete with that guy to start
wrestling when Cyril gone started
wrestling the the the the Gap is just
too wide across
so I think what I what I what I was
thinking is and when I bring up Jon
Jones is I remember
at the first Jon Jones fight I watched
was when he got uh dq'd against Matt
Hamill okay from the 12 to six out of us
yeah right that was my first experience
with him
the next thing I feel like I remember
and I may have seen some of his fights
in between then but is when he like beat
up this guy that was like trying to rob
this lady like the night of that was the
day he fought for the title right the
day he fought for the title he chased
down a guy who robbed someone and
tackled him and held him until the cops
came right and then and then we fought
Shogun and became the youngest ever UFC
champion yep so here's what I'm getting
at as I remember and I and this is going
to be in just kind of I'm interested in
your take on this because I watched it
happen with Jon Jones and I feel like I
watched it happen with kamaru as well
where it was like John and kamaru as
they came up right it's like John does
this thing where he stops this robber
and he wins the belt he beats Shogun who
is this kind of like you know him and
lyodo were these kind of like
unfigure-outable guys to me as a fan at
that time right like guys like how do
you beat Leona machito you can't for
because you can't even touch the guy
right at that time
and they were like inherently these like
good guys
that everybody was rooting for and then
both of them became these like
epically long-range Champions that then
became sort of like villains Camaro was
never a villain I feel like he is really
to me as a fan again who doesn't know
anything
and maybe it's the the it comes back to
maybe the celebrity like ego thing like
to the camera as a fan again I've never
met the guy he's probably great
but just as a cash watcher I went from
going I'm rooting for this guy to then
it be like the way he talks about
himself and I feel like Jon Jones was
the same way to me
is they became this like really like and
then John got in all this kind of like
turmoily stuff like well I don't think
you can compare the two and here's two
reasons why one have you ever seen
Camaro talk like you ever seen Camaro on
my podcast he's one of the nicest yeah
most down-to-earth friendly Smiley fun
guys there's what you're seeing is
kamaru the the Destroyer the dog the dog
is ready to go 100 that's the difference
and that's what I was trying to ask is
like signaling to all the other people
I'm going to smash you right and that's
what he's signaling and that's what I
think I was asking is like is that all
just perceived by me or is that yeah you
know what I mean it's part of the fun of
being a fan sure you know deciding what
you like and what you don't like and
personalities that you root for and
personality you root against and
sometimes you root against a guy and he
wins you over because he's so goddamn
good you're like I wanted that
[__] to lose but he's the
[__] greatest yeah John is very
different than Camaro John is what I
would describe is there's human beings
that have different temperament and
different minds and different mentality
and a ruthless competitive drive that's
almost terrifying to the ordinary person
that's Jon Jones Jon Jones is a bad guy
who's trying to be a good guy but that
got that guy if we were living a
thousand years ago he would be on a
horse with the biggest battle ax waiting
in the back jacking heads off and
everybody would be running and those
people have always existed these
dominators have always existed yeah but
John is like a genuinely sensitive
intelligent guy right who's trying to do
the right thing but he's a [__]
conqueror he's a [__] conqueror
that's that's that's the thing that's
inside of him that leads him to be the
goat and without that you don't get
there you don't if you're you're you
don't get that you don't get a Mike
Tyson without that you don't get a
Muhammad Ali without that you don't get
a Marvin hagglet without that you don't
get a you don't get that that there's a
thing inside some people that is a
driving force that allows them to
overcome the greatest around them it's a
Michael Jordan it's a 100 there's a
there's a thing man Tom Brady and those
[__] are hated they're always
hated for sure because you have to hate
them because you can't beat them it's
the 260-inch deer dude yeah like because
my me and my buddies were talking it's
like there's not like they're like man
that's not the Deer of a lifetime that's
the deer of 10 life yes most people
never see that right but it's even more
than that because you can just
accidentally stumble across the deer of
a lifetime you can't accidentally beat
Jon Jones there's a there's a thing
about it so he's goed over khabib he's
good over everybody now khabib's too
yeah khabib is in the conversation but
Mighty Mouse is in that conversation and
two Mighty Mouse to me if you want to
look at like a technical expression of
the greatness of martial arts he's as
good as anybody's ever done it when
Mighty Mouse was the Flyway champion and
the only problem is up besides sahudo
and a couple other guys like benavidez
and he was not dealing with guys that
are of the caliber of the guys that Jon
Jones was facing Jon Jones was facing
gossipson Glover to Shara he was facing
Daniel Cormier he was facing the elite
of the elite and he never [__] lost
even when he was doing coke and he
wasn't even training right that's how
goddamn good Jon Jones is right and when
you know when Jon Jones talks about
fights though you know when I had him on
the podcast one of the things that he
talked about some people don't really
watch tape or they only watch a little
bit they let their coaches do the work
Jon Jones studies everyone he studies
their Tendencies he's get it he gets in
his mind how when you throw that left
kick you did you make this little step
with your right foot you might do this
thing when you uh shoot for a takedown
where you keep your leg on you keep your
head on one side every time you might do
this thing when someone throws a right
hand you always lean to the left you
might do it and Jon Jones picked up that
Tennessee and that's how he knocked out
Daniel Cormier he knew Daniel Cormier
has a tendency to duck towards his right
side because he goes for that single on
the left leg and John caught him with
the perfect head kick
but it wasn't by the an accident he
[__] he set that up he set it up just
like Leon Edwards set up that head kick
on Camaro there's a there's a beauty of
that that's just manned in the middle of
chaos and anxiety and fear and and the
the [__] fog of War you figure out a
way to connect with this thing that you
saw in taping and training and in
preparation
so it's with John it's not an accident
that he's a goat even with his lack of
training even with his even with the the
K it's just like he's so [__]
talented that he almost needs another
Jon Jones to make him compete the way he
would the way make him train the way a
lot of these other guys do like he's so
good he can beat those guys without
being challenged by someone like him
right because Jon Jones has never faced
uh Jon Jones